talk before L thanks Jo um all right
great thanks for having me um so this is
work on subliner time algorithms
for um it's joint work with my student
Rari batari and Arch and Ray and then um
pet strus and his student
pster and it appeared at
IAL so what's the problem here it's one
of the sort of most simple problems in
linear algebra we're given a symmetric
Matrix a um and we want to comp
approximations to all of A's values it's
symmetric so a has n real values it's an
N byn Matrix we know that we can do this
nearly exactly or basically to extremely
high Precision in roughly n to the Omega
time with a full I decomposition or full
other Matrix
decompositions um but this is
prohibitively expensive for large n so
um if n is really large even something
like n s can be expensive we also know
that we can get really accurate
approximation of the igen values using
ative methods that basically repeatedly
multiply your Matrix via vectors this is
kind of like the methods that David
talked about yesterday like Matrix
Vector qu algorithms and very roughly
speaking I'm not going to go into the
details on these types of methods but
basically if I want to compute K values
like the largest kigen values or the
smallest kigen values it takes roughly K
Matrix Vector multiplications so if a
was like a dense Matrix it would take
like n^2 time K time very
roughly um in practice these are
these are the algorithms that are used
to compute large scale igen value
problems so iterative methods like if
you ran if you wanted to compute igen
values of large Matrix in python or
really any language they would use these
methods the question we're asking is
what if I don't want to pay n squar time
I want to go faster than that and in
particular we're basically asking can we
approximate the igen value Spectrum in
sublinear time um so if the Matrix is
dense which I'll just assume throughout
this talk just so I'm not talking about
like nza or something just n squ as my
Baseline time to read my Matrix I want
to run in like little o of n^ s time and
still get non-trivial approximation the
a
right so what I'm going to show today
the result that I'm presenting is
basically a really simple sublinear time
algorithm that approximates all the igen
values of a symmetric Matrix a up to
some additive error I'll explain sort of
the meaning of this error later but it's
basically scales as some error parameter
Epsilon the size of the Matrix n and
then the largest magnitude entry in that
Matrix um using polylog n over with in
polylog n in one over Epsilon samples um
the algorithm is Trivial I'm just going
to take my big Matrix I'm going to
sample a smaller principal submatrix
from that randomly and I'm going to
compute the IG values of the smaller
principal submatrix and use them to
approximate my original values so the
algorithms trivial the main work is
analyzing why does this give me good
approximations we're going to show some
improved results basically you can get
like less Force error bounds if you have
some more information about your Matrix
so if you can sample rows or columns
with probability proportional to either
their Norms or their sparsities which in
many settings you would have access to
this type of sampl um and then I'll
mention some open questions on some ler
time uh algorithms for igen Value
approximation and how they connect to
things like what David talked about
yesterday like um a query optimal uh
linear sketching algorithms R
[Applause]
value okay so our main result stated
slightly more formally is I have a
symmetric Matrix a um throughout this
talk I'm just going to assume that I
scaled a so that its largest magnitude
entry is bounded by one everything holds
in general but I just don't want to have
to keep writing a Infinity so just
assume the largest entry of the Matrix
is bounded by one what we show is that
there's an algorithm that reads log
cubed n divided by Epsilon to the fifth
entries of this Matrix and outputs a set
of anigen values such that for any I
value of my original Matrix my
approximate igen value is with an
Epsilon n of the true
UE actually I guess any questions on
just the problem where the approximation
guarantee for random Matrix Diagon Val
would be of order s right yeah I'll so
I'll talk about I'll talk in a bit about
when is this approximation guarantee
non-trivial if the random matri if you
have a random Matrix the I values will
roughly be square root of n so it could
just output all zeros so we're really
trying to detect like large I it this
really will be able to detect any large
I values um so for example if I have a
matrix which is like let's say I have a
random Matrix but it's like a gr Matrix
of a low dimensional random Matrix the I
values of this Matrix will scale with n
and so I'll be able to approximate the I
values of that but not of some general
random
[Applause]
Matrix yeah so let me talk about this
Rel the's question how good is plusus
Epsilon approximation to values is it a
good bound or is it trivial um one thing
you can note is that all the IG values
of your Matrix are always bounded by its
fbus norm and if I've scaled the entries
to be bounded by one they're all bounded
by n right so my approximation error is
Epsilon n so it's at least on order of
kind of the largest these IG values
could be
um if I want to look a little bit more
carefully at it the sum of
values is equal to the square forus Norm
which in my setting will be bounded by n
s so what this means is that there's at
most one Epsilon squared big igen values
basically there's at most one over
Epsilon squared values that are actually
bigger than Epsilon n for any Epsilon so
what this means is that I only give
non-trivial approximation to those igen
values so even though I have this like L
Infinity guarantee on approximating all
the IG values it's really only
meaningful for the top one over Epsilon
squ and this is maybe not super
surprising my athm is really fast it's
only running in poly one over Epsilon
time there's no way I'm going to be able
to approximate like actually all the IG
values so really I'm getting a good
approximation to any big IG values of
[Applause]
the and it's easy to see that this is
basically optimal so we don't know the
optimal Epsilon dependencies but you
definitely need additive error scaling
at least linearly in N times the
infinity Norm of the Matrix you just
can't avoid this I mean one reason you
can see why you definitely need a scale
in the infinity Norm is I could have a
matrix which just has like two insanely
large entries right if I'm sampling my
Matrix in sublinear time I'm never going
to find those entries so I don't know
and everything else is zeros let's say
so I don't know whether my igen value is
zero or whether it's some massive value
that's determined by those two entries
so if you have you definitely have error
that needs to scale on basically the
size of the entries of your Matrix and
it's not hard to show that you also have
to scale
in I think I'll show that next so any
questions on
this oh yeah justum symmetric or also
PSD I'm assuming symmetric if we can get
tighter results for PSD but I'm not
really gonna talk about it
yeah so actually if it was PSD there
would only be one over Epsilon outlying
I values you can check and this makes
things a little bit
easier Okay cool so here's the lower
bound instance which basically says that
if I want to get additive error Epsilon
N I definitely need to read like one
over Epsilon squ entry so this kind of
tells me if I'm just reading poly one
over Epsilon entries then I definitely
have error scaling in so the instance is
simple I either have an identity Matrix
whose Top igon Value is all of its I
values are one or I have this block
Matrix where it's basically the identity
with a big is block of ones so that's an
Epsilon n by Epsilon n block of ones
I've drawn it in the top left corner but
say I like permute the the rows and
Columns of the Matrix which doesn't
change the igen values but it hides
these ones right so they're scattered
throughout the Matrix the top I value of
this Matrix is large it's Epsilon n plus
one because or actually it's probably
just Epsilon n plus one but anyways it
has a big igen value if I read less than
one over Epsilon squ entries and I've
scattered these ones throughout the
Matrix with high probability I'll never
see a one I'm only going to read zeros
so I'm never going to be able to tell
apart these two matrices so basically we
know that if I want um error like
Epsilon n in my igen value approximation
I need to read at least one over
Epsilon so this is kind of the hard case
why we have to
[Applause]
scale okay so what's our algorithm
that's going to achieve our error
guarantees it's a trivial algorithm um
we're basically going to just take a our
big Matrix we're going to sample a
random principal submatrix so sample a
set of rows sample the same set of
columns look at at the intersection you
get a random principal submatrix the
rows and columns are sampled uniformly
at random and then we're going to
compute the IG values of the small
Matrix and use them to approximate the I
values of the big Matrix so it's a very
natural
[Applause]
algorithm um the sample size s is going
to be poly log n over Epsilon this is
going to be where our ventional sample
complexity comes from we're just going
to basically include each row or column
independently with probability s n we're
then going to scale up this matrix by a
factor of n / s to kind of keep
expectations in cor correct right if I
just sump sampled my Matrix then all the
igen values are going to proportionally
scale down so I'm scaling up by the
inverse of my sampling factor and then
I'm going to use those IG values to
approximate the IG values
of that's the
algorithm um one question here is like
as s only has roughly s values because
it's roughly s by S right um whereas a
has n values so I'll tell you in a
second how do I I get like align these
igen values it's very simple
though and then the other thing I wanted
to mention but I'm not going to talk
about in this talk is our actually like
the best result that I showed a few
slides ago we do a further
pre-processing step where we kind of
like randomly entry well what we do is
we literally randomly entry sparsify
this Matrix and using like known bounds
on Entry sparsification we argue that
this preserves the igen values and it
saves us a little bit in the sample
complexity but it's just an imization to
get better bounds so I'm not going to
talk about it in this I also think like
if our analysis was tight for the first
step we wouldn't need to do
this okay any questions about the
algorithm yeah is it clear it's better
to pick a submatrix and Sample within it
then like sample a bunch of things all
over and look at that it's not clear
it's a really good question so the lower
bound is what I showed a slide ago is
one over Epsilon squar and we're pretty
far off of that we're getting the best
we get is one over Epsilon to the fth
it's a great question to try to match it
I have no real idea how you would
basically sample like somehow one over
Epsilon squared entries throughout your
Matrix which is basically like no
entries it's very sparse I don't know
how you would then figure out igen value
approximations from them so I think it's
an interesting question because there
might be like a totally different
algorithmic approach that we haven't hit
upon yet so this is one question I think
would be fun to to work on thanks other
questions
here okay cool
um just to give you a sense of exactly
how the approximation works I compute
the igen values of this small Matrix as
I get a list of not very many igen
values and then to align them to the
igen values of a I need to approximate n
igen values I just like take the the
positive ones put them on the positive
side take negative ones put them on the
negative side and then anything anything
else I fill in with zeros and this is
just matching the fact that I'm only
expecting to approximate the large igen
values anyways right so the large igen
values of as
positive or negative approximate the
large ion values of a and everything in
between is small so I can just trivially
approximate it by zero okay so this is
my actual like list of approximate I
values
[Applause]
I okay um before I go into like sort of
how we prove this I just want to mention
um some other bounds that we have when
we have better sampling routines so here
I'm getting in the uh so consider for
example I'm still in the same setting I
have a symmetric Matrix a its entries
are bounded by one but now maybe it's
not dense and it has NN Za nonzero
entries which maybe is a lot less than n
right think about like a sparse
adjacency Matrix of a graph typically NN
Za is way way way less than n squ let's
say I can also nnz AI is the number of
entries in row I and let's say that I
can sample an index I proportional to
nnz of AI this is pretty simple to do if
you've stored your Matrix in sparse
Matrix format one thing you can do is
just sample random entry of the Matrix
and it will land in row I with
probability nzid n so if I have sparse
Matrix format this is kind of free to be
able to do
this so if we can do this if we can
sample with probability proportional to
sparsity we get an algorithm that has
also poly log n over Epsilon sample
complexity note that my polyes are way
worse here um but I get a much better
error guarantee my error scales as
Epsilon time square root of NN Za and
what's the meaning of that error
guarantee well the igen values remember
are bounded by the fenus norm which is
bounded by square root of N and Za if my
entries are bounded by one but this is
always less than n and if n and Za is
much much smaller than n then this will
be way way less I mean if this is much
less than n squ then this will be much
less than n so this gives a much better
error guarantee than our dense algorithm
right so if you're in a sparse graph and
you're thinking about n and Za scaling
linearly in N the error becomes square
root of n rather than
n
as I mentioned you can do this type of
sparsity sampling really efficiently um
it's also very related to um like
adjacency list queries in the standard
like um sublinear time graph algorithms
literature so these type of queries are
fairly reasonable to assume
um uh
yeah and then one thing I wanted to
mention here I'm not going to go I don't
know if I'm going to get to talk about
this result much but surprisingly our
algorithm here is not super simple what
we do is we basically sample this random
Principle submatrix as but we can
provably show that the igen values of as
are not good approximations to the ID
values of a we have to do this weird
step where we basically carefully zero
out certain entries of the sampled
Matrix that got scaled too much in order
to make sure that our igen value
approximation concentrated so this
algorithm is a little bit complicated
and that's reflected in this very bad
sample complexity like why we have a to
the 16 power so I think one interesting
question here is basically like what's
the right algorithm here that we could
then get towards a tight
bound okay any questions on that
result yeah that extra zeroing out
that's only necessary in the sparse case
yeah it's not necessarily in the uniform
case I'll I I think I'll have time to
explain where this comes from and if not
I can talk about it offline it's
actually also necessary in the next case
I'll discuss which I'm just going to go
over really quickly you can also assume
an even stronger sampling Oracle where I
can sample rows and columns proportional
to their squared ukian Norm if I can do
this I get a similar result but my error
gets even better now it scales with the
fbus norm of the Matrix so again just as
a comparison the igen values are always
less than the fbus norm Which is less
than square root of NN Za Which is less
than n so this is kind of like the
stronger form of sampling and I get
Epsilon times the fbus form and if
you're if you're in David's talk
yesterday this is the type of guarantee
that sketching methods give but
sketching methods aren't sublinear time
they have to like read the whole Matrix
right of course here I'm assuming this
stronger sampling Oracle right um this
type of sampling Oracle has been studied
for a long time in the randomized linear
algebra literature like some of the
early work on low rank approximation
assume this type of Oracle and they gave
results that looked a lot like this with
additive error Epsilon times the forb
form but recently it's received actually
a lot of attention in the literature on
like Quantum inspired algorithms because
basically um Tang made this real ation
that a lot of sublinear time Quantum
algorithms if you sort of compare them
head toad with classical algorithms if
you allow the same type of
pre-processing or the same type of data
structures to be used you actually
should be able to assume that you have
access to this Oracle and then Chi and
many other co-authors showed that if you
have access to this Oracle you can kind
of De quantize a lot of these Quantum
linear algebra so this is one way to
sort of view this type of result there
has been work on basically exactly the
same problem singular value
approximation rather than igen value
approximation which gives the same type
of additive error guarantee with the
same type of runtime um but using a
Quantum algorithm so you could think
about this as like a Quantum I mean I'm
not thinking about it that way but it
fits into the quantum inspir literature
in
that and in this result by the way we
also get the messy poly factors and this
is also because we have to do this
zeroing out
thing yeah so sampling model here
so the sampling model here is that first
you get to sample a row proportional to
Norm square and then you don't know the
locations of nonzeros yeah you don't
need to know the locations well actually
sorry in the quantum inspired model
typically what you can do because you
can build a fast data structure for
something where I sample a row
proportional to its norm and then I
sample entries within the row
proportional to their size that's
typically what's assumed we're not using
the full power of that model we just
sample independently s rows with
proportional to their norm and then we
form the principal submatrix from those
rows so we don't ever do entry y
sampling that's the same in the sparsity
case as well by the
way okay cool other
questions is there any reason to believe
that it would be useful in this
framework to sample several uh
submatrices and perform the same yeah
this is a great question so there's
prior work that I haven't gotten to yet
but there's prior work that solves a
weak kind of a weaker variant of this
problem where they're just trying
actually David again mentioned it
yesterday where you're just trying to
Tech the presence of a large negative I
value and to get tight results there
they actually do sample multiple
principal submatrices and sort of like
aggregate the results um we don't know
how to do that for our problem but it's
definitely something you could consider
doing yeah that's a great question okay
thank you
okay
cool let me mention some related work
before I try to like briefly sketch the
proof techniques um there's been several
works that study sort of sublinear time
property testing algorithms for matrices
in this bounded entry model we assuming
the the L Infinity Norm is bounded um so
Balan Lee Woodruff and Jen gave um
algorithms for doing things like testing
rank stable rank Matrix Norms um
and then the most closely related to
work to ours which is what I was just
mentioning with these principal some
matrices was this really nice work by
boxy chaper and JRM um which appeared in
Fox 20 and they basically gave um
similar complexity to ours like OTA one
over Epsilon poly Epsilon algorithms to
test if a is either positive
semi-definite or as one large negative
UE so in comparison to our to that work
um our result is stronger in the sense
that we approximate all the igen values
so once you have approximation of all
the igen values you can trivially just
check whether one of them was very
negative or not but their result has
better Epsilon dependence and they
actually get rid of the login dependence
entirely so they have tight bounds for
their problem whereas we don't have tip
bounds for our problem so that's another
Gap that uh in our work that could be
improved and then I'll just mention that
subsequent to our work there's been this
really nice line of work um there's
these two papers by nadell swap worth
and Woodruff who basically give optimal
igen value approximation algorithms in
The Matrix Vector query model which is
in some sense a very different query
model because you're multiplying your
matrix by a vector you need to access
all of its entries it's very much not
sublinear time but the techniques look
really similar and I think that maybe
like to get optimal bounds in our model
maybe some tools from what they're doing
could be used and I also mention that
this was studied a while ago by indoni
and WN who gave some weaker guarantees
but also studied igen value
approximation in streams using basically
linear
[Applause]
sketching and then finally I'll just
mention that there's several other works
recently that look at spectral density
estimation for certain types of
adjacency matrices of graphs like
normalize graph adjacency matrices here
you basically the spectral density you
view as a distribution placing Point
Mass one over n at each IG value and you
want to approximate this in like the
washer steam distance so there's this
really cool work that actually gives a
run time which is independent of n it's
like two to the one over Epsilon using
this sort of like random walk based you
basically run a bunch of random walks
and aggregate them to approximate your
spectral density there's work by
Braverman chrisan and um Chris MCO um
who give like an N over poly Epsilon
time algorithm um so it's better Epson
dependence but worse end dependence um
our result is really related to that
like we can easily convert our guarantee
to giving a guarantee in the washer
scene distance so we get Epsilon an
approximation in the washer scene
distance but um they're sort of
incomparable regimes because um the IG
values of a general Matrix with entries
bounded by one lie in the range negative
n to n and this is kind of intuitively
why have we have this scaling with n um
the I values of a normalized adjacency
matrix even though its entries can lie
are bounded in value by one they lie
between negative one and one so in their
work they get a much tighter bound like
scaling of Epsilon so it's just worth
noting that like it's very related but
two separate regimes they have a lot
more structure to work with and it tells
them a lot more about their I
[Applause]
Val okay and then just like the broader
research goal that I've been trying to
pursue for several years and a lot of
other people are working on is using
Randomness to give sublinear time
algorithms for natural linear algebraic
problems typically under some
assumptions on Matrix structure so
there's been all sorts of work on
algorithms for positive semi-definite
matrices or distance matrices kernel mat
Ates um these Quantum inspired
algorithms there's all sorts of work
here that's related done by a lot of
people in this room um often these get
stronger bounds but they assume some
structure whereas in our problem we're
just assuming that the Matrix is
symmetric we essentially have no other
structure sorry I think I missed
something in your implication for your
implication for wases distance I thought
your algorithms were saying that EP
anything's basically smaller than
Epsilon and you could freely give Z
isn't that Epsilon n s was distance yeah
so if you added up our guarantee our
total L Infinity Norm is like Epsilon n
s distance you have one over n
probability at each ion value so divide
by n so it just becomes Epsilon oh I see
so they okay and it's still the same
okay thank you yeah and so and then they
get they have that same exact metric but
they get Epsilon instead of Epsilon n
which is obviously way stronger yeah oh
I see and but so you're taking into
account that the interval is is killed
by okay thank you
thanks okay other
questions all right cool so with that
that's kind of the context that's the
results I'll go like briefly into the
proof approach I have to 12:30
right
um okay so just recall um we're gonna
have a uniformly random principal
submatrix we want to show that if I
scale that Matrix appropriately then the
igen values of this appropriately paded
with zeros approximate the Val of the
original Matrix and we want to show that
the sample size can be poly log one
Epsilon I'm going to get worse polom
factors in the talk than I do in the
paper because uh the ideas are the same
I'm not going to optimize
them the key ideas is simple it's
appeared in a lot of literature in this
area I basically split my Spectrum into
a head and a tail component so I split a
into its outlying igen values which are
basically bigger than Epsilon n these
are the ones that we expect to get
non-trivial approximation
and then it's middle values which are L
EPS n and like we're not going to get
nonrival
approximations okay so formally I like
look at the Ian decomposition of a um I
let like V be the outer IG vectors and
VM be the middle igon vectors and Lambda
o and Lambda M be the diagonal matricies
containing the big the outer and the
middle ion values um and then I can
write a in this way so I can write a as
basically a projected onto its large IG
directions plus a projected onto its
small I
Direction similarly I can write my
principal submatrix as the sum of two
principal submatrices the corresponding
principal submatrix of my projection
onto the outer IG directions plus the
submatrix on the projection onto the
inner Direction and so I'm going to
analyze it in this way by just thinking
about these two different components
separately
so so far I've written a as AO plus a
large igen values plus small igen values
and S transpose as which is my principal
submatrix I should say s is just it's
just a way of writing sampling in a
linear algebraic way it's just a
sampling operator that reduces the
number of rows and columns so um I'm
writing s transpose as as s transpose a
Zer S Plus sose
a my first step is I'm going to show
that the nonzero igen values of s trans
ose a z s approximate those of a z to
small error basically I preserve the
outer IG values this is going to be the
most interesting step of the
proof my second step is going to be to
show that the igen values of s transpose
a Ms are pretty small in magnitude like
less than Epsilon n basically I don't
care that I'm getting good approximation
of these I values I just don't want them
to blow up and look like fake large agon
values I want them to stay small so I'm
going to show that after sampling this
Matrix I don't blow up any of the small
igen values they stay
small and then I'm just going to combine
these via like an igen value
perturbation bound like via Wilds in equ
equality so if I know that I
approximated the large values to small
error and I know that the small igen
values remain small then via basically
like triangle inequality or WS
inequality as you call it for igen
values we know that we approximated all
the igen values to like roughly
Epson so these are really the two steps
that I need to
go
okay step one how do I approximate the
large Aon values I really like the proof
idea here and it's not our proof idea
it's from this boxy
cherco the idea is that since I've
assumed that my Matrix has bounded
entries all of its outlying igen values
like any big igen value correspond to
basically an incoherent igen Vector
which means that all the vectors that
witness large IG values are like well
spread vectors they're not sparse they
Place Mass at a lot of different entries
and thus they're pretty easy to
approximate via just uniform random
sample so this is not super hard to
prove so um let's take any unit Norm
igen Vector I know that a * V is equal
to Lambda time V that's what it means to
be an IG vector and you also know that
lambda's big it's at least Epsilon n in
magnitude right what this means is that
the ith entry of V is like one over
Lambda times the ith entry of Av right
because I just divide it by Lambda on
each
side the I entry of Av is just the inner
product between the I row of a and the
vector v which by Ki Schwarz is bounded
by the norm of that row times the norm
of V
right this is at most root n because I
assume my entries are all bounded by one
so I have a n length Vector its Norm is
at most root n and then V is a unit
Vector right and then this here is at
least Epsilon n because I assumed it's
an outling I so now I know that the the
magnitude of the I of Entry of V is at
most one Epsilon time Root
n so what this means intuitively is that
V is within like a one over Epsilon
factor of being perfectly flat if its
entries were all one over root n in
magnitude it would be perfectly flat we
have this one over Epsilon slot but
pretty much it's almost a perfectly flat
Vector I should be able to approximate
it really well via uniform
samp so any questions on this
proof it's pretty simple I mean well
it's very simple I guess so this proof
is an important part of this work by
Baki at all on testing PSD um we kind of
extend this to a stronger bound which
I'm not going to show today um we
basically show that not only is are the
igen value vectors entry-wise bounded
but in order to get a tight a tighter
result we show that if I basically look
at that whole outlying igen Vector
Matrix all of the row Norms of that are
bounded these are also known as The
Leverage scores of that Matrix I like to
work with leverage scores so like I
always focus on bounding these types of
quantities if we can down these we know
that sampling uniformly from that Matrix
will give us good approximations so we
give a stronger bound but this it's the
same exact idea as this
bound okay so so far we know that the
outlying igen space of incoherent of a
is incoherent meaning its masses spread
across the indices and its leverage
scores formula are bounded by roughly 1
n or 1ep
S what this means is via like a standard
Matrix Burnstein bound if we take one
over Epsilon to the fourth samples
eventually this will be one over Epson
cubed but again in the talk I'm not
worrying about getting tyght bounds then
with high probability if I basically
look at a sampled inner product so V is
an orthonormal Matrix right so V
transpose V is the identity if I sample
the rows of V uniformly at random
because they have bounded row Norm
V transpose SS transpose V so the
sampled inner product is going to be
close to the identity with High um via
like a standard Matrix burn value um we
can then use this to argue that the
non-zero igen values of our principal
submatrix are close to those of the
original Matrix So intuitively speaking
our principal submatrix can be written
as s transpose v0 Lambda 0 V transpose s
right that's almost an igen
decomposition because after sampling v0s
is almost orthogonal right so this is
almost an igen decomposition of this and
so these are almost the IG values of
this so basically our subsampled Matrix
its igen values are close to the
original igen values um of the Matrix
I'm not going through exactly how we do
these bounds but that's the intuition
behind
way so that completes the hardest part
of the proof which is showing that the
outlying IG values are close to uh the
True outling Value so questions on that
part of it
and the key here there is just that if
your entries are bounded the igen space
corresponding L values must be
incoherent meaning it must be easy to
approximate via
S it's kind of like in Matrix completion
like you always assume your igen space
is incoherent um and you get sublinear
type algorithms and so this is just kind
of a justification that if you have
large enough I values in your bounded
entries it must be
incoherent okay
it remains to show that the IG values of
the the S transpose AMS are bound in in
magnitude by Epsilon
M there's sort of two steps here
basically the first thing we we want to
do is show that because of the
incoherence of the outlying igen
space a Zer like after I take a and I
project it onto the outlying igen space
it might make the entries not be bounded
by one anymore which could kind of mess
up my arguments right but we show that
the entries are still bounded so even
after projection the entries are bounded
by like one Epsilon and then via
triangle in equality this tells me that
the entries of am are still bounded by
like one plus one over Epsilon so
they're reasonably bounded so basically
after projecting onto that igen space I
haven't messed up my entrywise bound all
that
much and then once I have that I can
just apply known spectral Norm bounds
for sampling random principal
submatrices of bounded entry matrices so
there's like a Bound by ruton ver shinan
I think we use an actual citation by
trop which is basically that if I have a
bounded entry Matrix and I sample random
principle sub matrix's I values can't be
too large is the type of thing that they
study a lot in sort of random
Matrix so the key step here is just
showing that am actually has bounded
entries that follows from incoherence
and then we get
[Applause]
this
okay so that's the entire proof just as
a recap I split a into its outling this
is very classic like its head and tail I
values outling middle values um I prove
that the outlying IG directions are
incoherent and thus I approximate them
via uniform sampling and I preserve the
outling igen vectors I then use that
incoherence to argue that the inner igen
directions after I project onto them the
Matrix remains bounded and when I sample
it the IG values don't blow up and then
I combine everything basically via
triangle
[Applause]
inequality okay any questions on that
and then I'll talk a little bit about
non-uniform samp in some open questions
yeah do you get anything about the
vectors if they're Gap the outer Val are
Gap you mean about trying to like
approximate the IG vectors well you have
it you get vectors of this compression
yeah yeah can you say it's the residual
when you look that back to original
space is
small yeah I don't know how to actually
lift it back properly to the original
space like oh what I was going to say
this the sub Matrix is basic a
compression yeah you can use that Matrix
to lift oh yeah but then you would get a
really sparse lifted igon Vector
right yeah maybe I do we expect it would
I have to think about that I kind of
think I wouldn't expect it would
actually have a strong small res draft
lifting it but it's a great question we
should look at that yeah yeah so in
theory like you could if you add an i
Vector to this Matrix you could then
like call it X you could then look at SX
and say like is this a reasonable IG
Vector of the original Matrix certainly
it's not a large IG Vector because it's
sparse and we know all the large vectors
are dense but you could still ask like
what are the properties of this I don't
necessar expect it would have small
[Applause]
residual yeah in the sketching methods
like where this is a gaussian matrix you
probably can do some lifting like
this other questions on
this yeah you
suspected so you said that you suspected
that the zeroing out argument does not
need to be done if the like there's
something sharpened here you have any
sense of what part of this analysis is
the part that would need to be sharpened
oh um I'll get there I haven't actually
the analysis I just did there is no
zeroing out I just take the principal
subm matrial and compute its igen
vectors yeah but he said that the
zeroing out is done in order to like get
slightly better rates but that you
wouldn't do yeah so the zeroing out is
done when I do non-uniform sampling I'll
talk about that in a second and that's
where we lose a lot of Epsilon factors
got the bound we get here is one over
Epsilon cubed and I'm almost sure the
correct bound is one over Epsilon
squared we've like simulated a lot tried
to find worst case matrices this is
what's known for linear sketches I don't
really know how to shave that last
Epsilon it's a little technical where it
comes from but basically like very
intuitively it it doesn't come out in
the proof I described but the
interactions between really big and
really small Aon vectors can kind of
mess you up and we lose an Epsilon
Factor there so it can probably tighten
but I don't know how to do it co thank
[Applause]
you all right cool so actually like that
that's a good segue into non-uniform
sampling I'm not going to prove these
results at all I'm just going to tell
you in a minute why things get a little
bit weird in the nonuniform samp case um
so we have a natural extension of our
algorithm I just sample each row or
column with some probability Pi which is
non-uniform in this case I'll consider
the sparsity based sampling I take D to
be a diagonal matrix which appropriately
rescales by like one over square root of
the probability and then I compute the
igen values of like DD so this is my sub
Matrix appropriately rescaled so it's
correct in expectation and then I just
use these values to approximate
it okay if my probabilities were uniform
this is exactly the same as my uniform
sampling algorithm so it's exactly just
a a a generalization of that
algorithm immediately you can see that
this algorithm completely fails when a
is the identity so if a is the identity
sparcity based sampling is just uniform
sampling n and Z of a is n right so we
need to approximate all the igen values
to error roughly like root n if we want
to get our
bound but when I sample this principal
submatrix I'm just going to get an
identity out and I'm G to scale it by
n/s so the igen values of my sample
Matrix are going to all be
n/s so if I want to get error root N I
would need to set s at least like root n
so I'm not going to get like a poly log
dependence so my algorithm just fails
for the identity it's like okay this
algorithm just doesn't
work a simple fix here is you can zero
out the diagonal of a you can show that
this doesn't affect the igen values too
much um and it resolves this one case
but you might suspect that this sounds
like a Band-Aid like it fixes the
identity case but there must be some
other similar cases right and there are
so for example consider this like almost
identity Matrix where you just have two
bands of
ones like right above and below the
diag again again n and Za is roughly n
so root n and Za is roughly root n and
the IG values are all constant they're
all less than two um so I need to
basically approximate the IG values to
error root n and again I'm roughly doing
uniform sampling because pretty much
every row and column here is n and Z has
two nonzeros so my Matrix I get out is
like n/ s times my
sample if I take very few samples then
with good probability my sample Matrix
is just zero I don't hit any of these
ones right um and so we actually get
good estimates we get lucky in a way but
if I take a bit more samples then by
birthday Paradox with good probability I
hit one of these non-zero entries and
when I hit it I scale up a lot and then
the igen values of my Matrix are big
they're like basically like root n over
C if I took C root n samples and this is
above my error guarantee so this isn't
necessarily a problem like you could
just say don't take too many samples
but it kind of hints at a problem I
don't want an algorithm that as I start
taking more samples it starts failing
and there's lots of similar cases to
this that will kind of destroy the
algorithm and yeah so there's many
related examples roughly what happens is
if I have entries that are at the
intersection of very sparse rows and
columns and I hit those entries by bad
luck I scale them up way too much when I
sample and it messes up my eye
and um so I'm not go into the details
how I deal with this but I just wanted
to point it out because it leads to an
interesting open question basically to
handle these cases we just zero out
entries that are at the intersection of
sparse rows and columns and we ignore
them when we sample um this ensures that
none of them are scaled up too much and
we don't have any issues like I
described on the last couple slides um
and we prove that the zeroing out
basically doesn't affect the igen values
too much so it doesn't introduce too
much error um so you can see the paper
for the full argument but the upshot is
basically like we get a bound which I'm
happy with we lose tons of log n and one
over Epsilon factors and I'm really not
sure like what the right algorithm is
here like if you had told me what's the
right algorithm to estimate IG values if
you know the row and column Norms I
would have said yeah sample the rows and
columns with proportional to those norms
and take the IG values of the principal
submatrix it's surprising that algorithm
fails and I kind of Wonder like what's
the clean right algorithm that gets like
tight bounds is kind of
AC okay so I have like a couple minutes
left I'll just conclude with some open
questions um actually wait maybe I can
take are there any questions on the
zeroing out stuff or the non-uniform
S so I'll talk about some open questions
so are uniform sampling bound we sample
a one over Epsilon Cube by 1 Epson Cube
submatrix we believe this can be tighten
to one over Epsilon
squ uh based on simulations and also
just kind of it looks like one should be
correct that also would match what box
shap at all get for PSD testing which is
a closely related problem um that would
also match a lower Bound for any
algorithm that works by first sampling a
principal submatrix and then doing some
post-processing right so that would be
tight for sit principal submatrix based
algorithms it actually wouldn't be tight
in general the best lower bound this is
like one over Epsilon to the fourth
entries in total the best lower bound we
have for General Al is one over Epsilon
squared so conceivably there could be an
entirely different class of algorithms
that does even better and I would be
really interested to know like what that
class would be
um I'll also mention another evidence
that this bound may be correct is that
when a is PSD there's a trivial proof
based on approximate matrix
multiplication that gets this bound and
loses no log n factors or anything so I
didn't go through that but that's
another maybe evidence that we could
tighten our Bound in the general case
um okay and then okay more evidence I
for I kind of forgot to order my slides
if I just care about the singular values
right the singular values of the
magnitudes of the igen values so
approximating the singular values is
kind of like approximating the igen
values but where you lose the
signs just via a very simple Matrix burn
SC Mount argument if I independently
sample some rows and some Columns of a I
can prove that the singular values
concentrate and I just need one overon
square so I can actually approximate the
singular values very easily with the
trivial proof but somehow getting these
signs correct and the fact that we do
like a principal submatrix s transpose
as makes things a lot more
complicated um there's been recent work
that David talked about yesterday that
gets tight bounds in the sketching model
where instead of looking at a sampling
they look at a bilinear sketch G TR was
AG so maybe we can use some techniques
there to tighten our bounds although
something that's kind of annoying is
that this result that David has only
works for gausian sketching matrices
which is very rare usually when you
prove sketching results they work for
like any subian sketching Matrix or like
even broader classes it only works for
gausian sketching matrices which
annoyingly means it doesn't like easily
generalized to like usually in my view
anything you can do with sketching
eventually we figure out how to do it
with sampling um but I'm not we're not
able to do that here because this is a
kind of a weird form of sketching where
you really need gaussianity and um
rotational
invariance okay and then sorry I'm out
of time there's other questions like um
I mentioned this one already can we get
tight sample complexity overall what's
even a plausible algorithm here can we
do anything interesting in the case when
we have small igen values so this is
related to like Nel's question at the
beginning if I have a random Matrix all
of its IG values are roughly like root n
the sum of its absolute values of IG
values which is called the shat and one
Norm is like n to the three halves
roughly can we approximate that shat and
one Norm to error even like one half
times Epsilon to the three havs like
anything non-trivial like can I figure
out whether I have a full rank random
Matrix or a random Matrix with rank n
over two we have no idea we have no
lower bounds or upper bounds there we we
know obviously you can read the whole
Matrix and do it we have no lower bounds
ruling out sublinear algorithm so I
think that's a really good question and
would kind of get at this key challenge
of how do we estimate like bulk spectral
properties like do I have a big tale of
small AG values or only a small
tail and then of course like something I
like to work on a lot and related to
these graph adj is if I assume further
structure it can I get tighter all right
that's it Sor I ran a little bit
over
[Applause]
yeah any questions for Cameron
so is there any notion of like a
different kind of information we could
have about rows of cons like if you know
the leverage scores of every row is
there any hope you can do better there
since leverage scores already appearing
in the
analysis yeah one way you could view all
of our algorithms is basically
successive um Le better approximations
to The Leverage scores like uniform is
not so bad because we know the leverage
scores are close to UNI uniform nnca is
a bit better the rorm is a little bit
better um if you actually knew the
leverage scores of the outlying EM space
I think you could get one over Epson
squared I'd have to double check that
I'm not 100% sure the problem is how are
you g to learn those leverage squares
you don't know what that space is but
yeah it's a good question thank
you
question
the next start the next Talk starts at
2m